so let me show you where i work this is  here my desk and building radar let me  show a couple of essentials that i use  almost every day first of all a good  headphone mainly using this for customer  conversations it's important with the  noise cancelling of other people and the  office that you can still have some high  quality conversations without  interruption besides that a high quality  keyboard i do need to write a lot of  emails and other texts it was important  to me to have a good one besides that i  always have some serious here next to me  just always when i have some quick  hunger maybe wasn't able to have proper  lunch then i can just quickly make  something for myself that's always  helpful and then of course also a nice  sports bag to head to the gym thankfully  enough we have a gym right around the  corner one of the big advantages here